number one
no one is like me you already know
Margot Robbie can do it all you might
know her best from her work as Harley
Quinn but that role is far from being
the only one she's made more than
memorable number one there's a song
title in there somewhere you already
know the first Suicide Squad was about a
whole Squad of your favorite villains
margos certainly stood out amongst them
and it wasn't only because of her
striking appearance margot's mad improv
skills probably helped but more on that
soon you might agree when we say that
Margo has something else about her a
special kind of charm we know you loved
her on-screen performance as Harley
Quinn and we hear that the entire crew
enjoyed working with her on set too
number two she's no stranger to snakes
you might have heard that on the set of
Suicide Squad actor Jared Leto developed
an odd habit of giving strange gifts to
his Suicide Squad co-stars this may have
led to some awkward situations and it
seems like no one was spared Jared gave
Margot a gift from The Joker too I
opened a box and there was a live snake
in it and although that may have
terrified other castmates Margot didn't
seem to mind she explained I had snakes
like literally in my house growing up
not on purpose like by you know they
would get into the house or whatever
number three she'll do it live you might
have heard that on the set of Suicide
Squad Margot seemed to share a special
connection with castmate Jared Leto
Margot hints at their unusual connection
when she tells of how the two didn't
feel the need to rehearse their scenes
they would just get right into
ad-libbing and improvising their way
through the scene this seemed to work
for both Margot and Jared Robbie said
I'm not trying to laugh because he says
such hilarious things Jared's really
funny and and terrifying and just nuts
absolutely nuts number four the truth
will set you free or at least make you
laugh Margot shared a number of funny
moments with co-star Will Smith who she
also established a friendship with
between takes will would make her laugh
scare her once in a while
and they would also tease each other a
lot for bad guys it's what we do number
five just take a seat and have a look
through the catalog you wanna try stuff
there was another challenge for Margo
but this one you might say she made for
herself Margo likes to give people
tattoos you heard that right Robbie said
first I had to really beg people and
then it kind of became a thing after
suicide squad it seems that more than a
few people wanted a Margot Memento
tattoo but one of them didn't quite get
what he was looking for Margo explained
I was writing a word and I spelled it
wrong The Story Goes that Margot had to
write the word squad spelled
s-k-w-a-d but something went wrong
Margot said I went straight from the s
to the W poor guy he'll probably never
forget working on set with Margot Robbie
or his trip to margot's tattoo parlor
number six no boys allowed okay well
maybe a few while Margo seems to be able
to make friends anywhere you might agree
that she liked working with her female
cast mates the most when asked who she
thought was the most attractive Suicide
Squad member Margot said I'm sitting
next to uh and pointed to cara de Levine
Birds of Prey had a female Squad of
villains and for Margot it was a special
experience to work on because you don't
often see so many women in action movies
barabi it's been a while since she saw
one that really did it for her Margot
had a lot of fun with her female
co-stars while making Birds of Prey they
even made a song about the film with the
hit hit
number seven
done makeup and ready for more makeup
you might say that playing Harley Quinn
became quite an experience for Margot
Robbie and there were some challenges
along the way before Margot even stepped
onto the set of birds of prey Robbie had
spent two and a half hours in the makeup
chair you might find it surprising that
according to Margot two and a half hours
was quite a relief boat body paint that
takes a long time in the first Suicide
Squad movie Marco's transformation would
take as long as six to seven hours so
how does that add up you ask Margot
breaks it down for you then you've got
to do multiple sealers and skin prep
involver it's not easy being Harley
Quinn then you got to do all the tattoos
then you gotta do the wig then you've
got to do the face and then you've got
to do the continuity blood and bruises
number eight egg sandwich hold the eggs
please
you might have heard there was another
challenge facing Margot on set having to
eat Harley Quinn's favorite egg
sandwiches turned out to be a chore
because Margot is allergic to eggs the
actress explained there is protein in
chicken egg whites that can give people
migraines and I get it luckily the crew
was able to help her with these dietary
restrictions by replacing the chicken
eggs with duck eggs for her onset meal
moments ah with the perfect egg sandwich
number nine hey she's walking here
working on the Wolf of Wall Street meant
that Margot had to learn to speak with a
Brooklyn accent so she met with an
acting coach Marlo recalls one of the
dialect coaching sessions okay pretend
that you've got acrylic nails on and
they've just been painted so they're
still wet Margo thought that was great
but how would she do the accent and the
coach said just do it while the tips
might have seemed odd they did do the
trick Margo's voice was magically
transformed I was talking to her and you
know this attitude came out of nowhere
for a very very very long time number 10
mom don't look
on The Wolf of Wall Street saw at least
one challenge for Margot you guessed it
it was about appearing nude on set but
this wasn't because she was too shy
Robbie once stated that she would agree
to take her clothes off in a scene if it
was necessary if it's Justified and the
character would do it then it should be
there the situation with nudity only
became awkward for Margo when she took
her mom to the premiere the actress said
I actually tried to cover her eyes when
the nude bits happened but she pushed my
hand away after the film Mama Robbie
claimed that she actually liked the nude
scenes saying they were done very
Tastefully and within context number 11.
as you might imagine working on the Wolf
of Wall Street was a dream come true for
Margot working with Martin Scorsese and
Leonardo DiCaprio must have been an
awesome experience for Margot one good
thing led to another she later got to
co-star with Leo again in the Quentin
Tarantino film Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood Margot had a blast on set with
Leo and her other cast mate Brad Pitt
Margot described just how exciting a
group like that could be I don't know
how much I'm elevating the situation but
definitely just Brad and Leo is like
people just lose their minds number 12.
a long time ago on a continent far away
you might have wondered where did the
acting Journey begin for Margot Robbie
let's go back a bit and have a look at
how this actor Rose to fame you could
fairly say that Marco's big break in
Hollywood happened when she starred in
The Wolf of Wall Street with Leonardo
DiCaprio and Jonah Hill but before that
Blockbuster Marco was well known in
Australia for her work on the popular
series Neighbors Margot explained when I
was working on neighbors you could be
across a football field and people would
be like chick from Neighbors Donna and
it's like oh my God she thought Fame was
tricky even then
consider this your first lesson
it's been quite a journey for Margot
Robbie and if you said she deserves all
the successes she's enjoyed we'd have to
agree like that size like that sure we
know we must have missed at least a few
of your favorite Margot moments so what
did you think I'm gonna be friends let
us know in the comments below